-My next guest
is an Emmy-nominated performer
who you know
from "Saturday Night Live."
She also stars in the new show
"Schmigadoon,"
which premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
Everyone, please welcome back
Cecily Strong!
-♪ Cecily Strong ♪
♪ She knows how to jive ♪
♪ She is the woman ♪
♪ From "Saturday Night Live" ♪
Cecily Strong
♪ Coming at you soon ♪
♪ Hope she's explanin' ♪
♪ What is a Schmigadoon ♪
-Cecily Strong!
That's a --
That's a standing ovation.
-Oh, that's sweet!
-They love you.
Come on.
-How nice.
-They love you. I love you, too.
Thank you for
coming on the show,
but thank you for doing
a sketch with us.
-Oh, it's so much fun.
You know I love to sing
and dance with you, Jimmy.
-I know.
We always have fun doing it.
I got to say the Emmys
were announced,
and you got your second
Emmy nomination.
Congratulations.
Well-deserved.
-Thanks. It was very nice.
And it feels like it was a good
celebration, I got to share
with a lot of my cast mates
who were making history.
I mean, Aidy Kenan
got the double.
-Oh, that's right.
Aidy Bryant. Kenan Thompson.
That's right.
-And Bowen.
-And Bowen Yang.
-First time a feature player.
-I always want to call you
on a Sunday.
Thank God
I don't have your number.
'Cause I just want to be like --
Or text you and say,
"That was the funniest thing
you've ever done."
-I've given you
some fake numbers.
-Yes, you actually have.
You and Don Cheadle.
-For that purpose.
Yeah, no one gives me
their real number.
But you do -- And every week,
you top yourself.
And you crush it every week.
And, you know,
everyone loves you.
But, dude, Jeanine Pirro?
-It's very fun.
And she loves me the most.
-But you going into
the giant box of wine.
-Yeah.
-Singing "My Way"
and just whipping wine
at Colin Jost.
-Why not?
Colin loves it more than anyone.
I've never seen
anything like it.
-You know what's great?
It looks like it's so much fun
that you're having out there.
That's the secret
to the whole thing.
-I mean, and it's like you can
tell them, "Fine, if I'm going
to do Pirro again, I need to..."
"Well, I barfed wine last time,
so I should get in a tub of wine
this time."
-You'll top yourself.
-And then they're like --
Richie's like,
"Okay, we'll figure it out."
-Yeah, Richie.
-Yeah, yeah.
And then, I mean,
even, like, the safety guy
at some point said to me
beforehand -- He was like,
"Okay, I've tested getting
into the grapefruit juice."
And I kept going,
"Why grapefruit juice?
What does that even look like?"
I think it was grape juice.
So that was a weird thing.
-That's sticks in your head?
-"Have you been throwing
grapefruit juice in your eyes?"
And he kept saying,
"Don't open your eyes
in the grapefruit juice.
It stings."
And I was like,
"What do you think
I'm going to be doing in this?"
-Yeah.
-In the tub like...
"Shape of Water."
-Just jumping in
and dunking quick.
-I don't know
that you had to throw
grapefruit juice in your eyes.
-It was a good warning
from him,
but you crushed it either way.
I want to talk
about "Schmigadoon."
I've heard about this.
I knew it going into production.
I was like,
"Oh, this is gonna be..."
You. Keegan-Michael Key.
-I love it so much.
-Dude, the production
on this thing is insanity.
-Yes, yeah.
-Can you set it up in a
couple lines or what it's about?
-Sure. I think so. I hope so.
-Yeah.
-It's a couple that is kind of
at a stale point
in their relationship.
They're doctors,
and they go on a hike,
as one does, to fix it.
-Yeah.
-And they get lost in a town
that turns out to be a musical.
And they can't leave
until they find true love,
which is strange to hear
if you think you're in love.
-That's what I'm talking about.
I love that.
They're stuck in this town.
-Yeah.
-And, by the way,
some heavy hitters in this.
Alan Cumming. Kristin Chenoweth.
-Yes.
-She -- How powerful --
-She's unreal.
I feel like she made
a quotable line
out of every line she had.
-Yeah.
-She was just like,
"Oh, yes, you do!"
Just does -- And I was like,
"Wow. That's how --
You can, 'Yes, thank you.'"
Or just, "Ahem."
-Yeah, just a --
-I guess no one says "Ahem."
-No one does "Ahem."
-That's how it's written,
but that's not how you say it.
-[ Clears throat ]
-Ahem!
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Cecily Strong
in "Schmigadoon."
Take a look at this.
-So, you have a feller?
-Y-Yes, I have a feller.
-And he's okay with you
walking on your own at night,
talking with strange men?
-Well, he's...
What's the question again?
-Wait a minute.
What are you trying to do?
Are you trying to get me
to fall for you?!
-What? No.
-Well, then why do those
crazy kind of thoughts
keep running through my head?
-Oh, I don't really --
-Well, you can forget it.
Because no woman is gonna tie
Danny Bailey down, no how.
-Sure.
-♪ When a squirrel
wants another squirrel ♪
♪ He don't bother
to get attached ♪
-Oh, I get a private show.
-Come on!
-That was me.
-You know how to do it
right there!
Cecily Strong, everybody!
Oh, you're one of my favorites.
Come back whenever, buddy.
"Schmigadoon" is streaming
on Apple TV+ this Friday.